Jean ensuite a vu le plafond coulé comme
si le plâtre n'était pas pris
puis il s'est cru au bord de la mer 4
heures plus tôt ils avaient croqué
chacun un sucre imbibé de 250
millionième de grammes de LSD
[Musique]
nous suivons ici les deux dernières
heures de l'expérience qui dure
maintenant depuis quatre heures
de tango
c'est belle je suis très très beau comme
ça
non ça supprime certains reflets dans le
qui prend l'importance parce que c'est
un peu
je récupère personne
sur mes yeux c'est
hélène a éprouvé la première les effets
du LSD elle a eu chaud elle a eu froid
elle a senti ses Nuxe alourdir ses joues
se durcir elle se plaignait puis elle a
commencé à voir le tapis grouillé de
serpent les murs se déformaient les
visages se rétrécit autour d'elle
Jean ensuite a vu le plafond coulé comme
si le plâtre n'était pas pris
puis il s'est cru au bord de la mer
c'était merveilleux puis c'était la
tempête
4 heures plus tôt ils avaient croqué
chacun un sucre imbibé de 250
millionième de grammes de LSD
maintenant il délire doucement chacun de
son côté
voilà
à côté de moi ce que j'entends c'est le
bruit du magnétophone
[Applaudissements]
oui et puis
attends je regarde
[Applaudissements]
elle aime croire bouger un poisson
d'argent
[Applaudissements]
le LSD les rapproche ils vont délirer
ensemble jusqu'à la fin ils sont
emportés par la drogue absolument Annie
il est par elle
oh là là
je sens plus mon corps du tout
je sais plus du tout
le film que la pression avait voulu
[Applaudissements]
en revoyant cette expérience
on leur envoyant sur le film on a
sur l'écran on a l'impression de l'avoir
à faire des personnes qui ne sont
absolument étrangères enfin quant à moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez quand même un souvenir
précis
oui très bien
et là vous arriviez sceptique
[Musique]
oui c'est un peu ce qui m'attirait dans
cette expérience c'est que
j'étais sceptique enfin plus exactement
je pensais que le l'utilisation de la
drogue demandait de la part de
l'utilisateur une complicité
et quand vous êtes arrivés là au moment
de l'expérience est-ce que vous avez eu
peur est-ce que vous avez regretté
d'être là oh non absolument pas une
certaine appréhension pour moi non pas
du tout et est-ce que ça vous gênait de
faire cette expérience de voir des
témoins non c'est mon pote ça pouvait
donner
le fait qu'il y ait des témoins c'était
plutôt rassurant et d'échapper à son
propre contrôle devant des témoins
est-ce que ce n'est pas terrorisme si ça
c'était jeune on entend c'était des
personnes
amis on était en confiance
[Applaudissements]
24 ans
43 ans et le métier que vous faites un
retouche photo de publicité
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir enrichi le champ de vos
perceptions oui oui tout de même
beaucoup même et ce qui vous en reste
quelque chose d'utilisable non
absolument pas
est-ce que vous pourriez écrire dessus
non
peindre si je savais pas dans la rigueur
encore pas faire très vite parce que ça
s'oublie
vous avez un souvenir précis de ce que
vous avez vu oui mais ça s'estompe quand
même
c'était en somme plutôt agréable ou
plutôt désagréable
plutôt agréable et si c'était à refaire
est-ce que vous le recommencerez
[Applaudissements]
je pense que chacun doit réagir d'une
façon différente à la drogue mais pour
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a plus du tout de volonté on ne sait
pas ce que ce que la droite va
vous faire faire ça doit révéler des
sentiments violents et si on les éprouve
les décuplés
violents pour moi je me souviens pas
[Applaudissements]
hélène a eu beaucoup de
vision concrète et moi c'était très
abstrait
pour moi les visions que j'avais
par exemple je voyais des feux
d'artifice avec des couleurs absolument
extraordinaires enfin je dis feu
d'artifice c'était ce qui peut se
rapprocher le plus de ce que je voyais
si on va quand même des choses des
couleurs sont très belles
on voit ce que l'on veut voir c'est
comme important
il y a beaucoup d'imagination sans avoir
des fleurs on voit des fleurs des peut
voir n'importe quoi suite de vouloir
[Musique]